you want to know secret of course you do
we all do we love hearing secrets and in
some cases we even like telling them but
modern living isn't really set up for
secrets emails instant messages sex they
all have an annoying permanence to them
popping up in the wrong places after
more than a decade of hyper connectivity
social networks and the broadcasting of
every thought and utterance perhaps the
pendulum is finally swinging in the
other direction favoring the private
over the public the discreet over the
distributed and the ephemeral over the
eternal several companies are trying to
cash in on this they go by names like
whisper secret and confide whisper was
the first company to step into this
category and it created an anonymized
Twitter of sorts allowing you to post in
public but keep your identity to
yourself secret took the idea one step
further connecting your contacts and
Facebook friends to you who also use the
app secret won't tell you who said what
but it will tell you if it's a friend or
a friend of a friend
confide is a little different it lets
you send text messages that
self-destruct after they've been read if
that sounds familiar
it's because it's basically the text
message equivalent of snapchat that
service that lets you send photos that
delete themselves after they've been
seen snapchat was in the news last year
when it turned down a three billion
dollar purchase order from Facebook and
recently the company was said to be in
talks with Alibaba valuing snapchat at
10 billion dollars companies trafficking
in secrets rumor and gossip still have
some hurdles ahead of them both secret
and whispers user agreements allow the
services to share user data with law
enforcement or under subpoena so you're
not truly unknown if a lawyer comes
after you
but there's no denying the allure of
these apps and services on some level we
are still all high schoolers with
secrets and confessions and these apps
give us an outlet furthermore they're
free so go ahead give them a shot I
won't tell